- [Voiceover] What is the missing number,
100, 101, 102, 103, 104, 105,
106 is the missing number,
and then we go 107, 108, 109, 110.
So, the missing number is 106,
that's the number after 105
and before 107.
Let's keep going.
What is the missing number?
Well, if I start at 100, the
next number is going to be 101,
and then we go to 102,
103, 104, we keep going.
This is exciting.
What whole number comes right before 105?
Well, what whole number
comes right before five?
Well, four.
So what number comes right before 105?
Well, it's going to be 104.
If you're going after 100 you
get 100, 101, 102, 103, 104,
and then you go to 105.
All right, so they want us to figure out
what the missing number is.
And we see that they're
counting, one, two three,
all the way up to 10 and then here
they're going from 11 to 20.
They're counting all the way up to 120.
But there's a missing square here.
So, this is the number
that is one larger than 118
and one less than 120.
Well, if I was counting, I'd
go 111, 112, 113, 114, 115,
116, 117, 118, 119, and then 120.
Nineteen is before 20,
so 119 is gonna be before 120.
And 19 is after 18 so the number after 118
is going to be 119.
Let's check our answer.
Let's do one more of these.
Well, we've done these a lot already.
What number is missing?
Right after seven comes
eight, so right after 107
comes 108 and then 109 and 110.